The first thing that it's important to notice about the supplied code is that in the array angles,
the angles are measured in degrees but as we said earlier,
the cosine and sine functions in Python's math library take arguments
that are measured in radians not in degrees.
So first thing that we need to do is convert each of the angles in the array angles into radians.
We do that by multiplying each angle by π and dividing by 180.
This gives us a new variable angle in radians or angle rad.
The next step is to set the initial position and velocity of the particle.
As you can see from these two lines, we've decided that
the particle is going to be in a zero in both the horizontal and vertical planes.
This means that it's starting at the origin.
Moving on to velocity, we set both the horizontal and the vertical velocity
by taking the initial speed which we set up here,
and multiplying by the cosine of the angle which we just converted
for the horizontal velocity or the sine for the vertical velocity.
Lastly, we finally make use of the Forward Euler Method.
If we want to find out what the position after the next step is going to be,
then we begin with a position at the step they were at
and then add the time step times the velocity at that present step.
You remember that this makes sense in terms of units because h is measured in time
and v is measured in distance over time which makes this term
also measured in distance just like x.
We do something very similar with velocity except that this time,
the acceleration is a constant which we set up here as the gravitational constant.
This means that the value of the acceleration is not going to change
from step to step although the value of the velocity will.
Something else that you might want to know is that we've only set the range
to go from 0 to num steps - 1.
You might initially have thought that we should insert num steps +1 as the argument of the range.
But because we're looking at the step +1 row in both x and v,
we need to restrict the range to be one less than we would have otherwise needed.
In fact, I made this error myself when I was looking over the code.
So it makes perfect sense if you were thinking that too.
After all this has been filled in, we can run the program and get this plot.
Now this is a plot of the position, not of the velocity.
You can see that the horizontal axis measures the horizontal position in meters.
The vertical axis measures the vertical position in meters.
Each different series here corresponds to each different element in the angles array.
As you can see, because each of these particles is leaving out a different initial angle.
>From this graph, we can see that as we change the initial angle,
we also drastically change where the particles going to end up landing.
Now, we move on to a problem that combines both this idea of ballistic trajectory
and the idea of orbits from the previous problem.